Donald Trump has not been a fan of the
intelligence community for months he
denied over and over and over and over
and over again the intelligence
community's conclusions that the Russian
government actors were behind the
WikiLeaks targeting Hillary Clinton now
Trump accuses the intelligence community
of leaking information about a
confidential briefing Trump went on a
rampage on Twitter against the
intelligence community over the lakes he
said quote intelligence agencies should
never have allowed this take news too
deep into the public one that shot of me
I really dig in Nazi Germany Trump says
the briefing did not include information
from the now infamous BuzzFeed report
that accused Trump of being in bed or
peeing on the bed with the Russian
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper suggests that Trump was informed
of such reports and says the
intelligence community was not
responsible for the leak so is the
intelligence community at war with Trump
if so that's no real shock commentators
have said for month that anyone who
attacks the intelligence community will
find themselves on the wrong end of
nasty leaks Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer threatened Trump quote let me
tell you you take on the intelligence
community they have six ways from Sunday
to get back at you so even for a
practical supposedly hard-nosed
businessman is being really dumb to do
this and the left has accused the
intelligence community of tossing the
election to trump as way of targeting
Hillary Clinton thanks to FBI director
James Comey announcement a week and a
half before the election that Hillary's
emails were still under investigation
there's actually kind of frightening
stuff the intelligence community is not
its own government independent executive
agencies that have access to classified
information are inherently dangerous
they require a high level of trust to
function well in a democracy pitting
them against a democratically elected
political actors is a recipe for
destroying both the credibility of the
intelligence community and the
credibility of those government actors
it creates the perception that a shadow
government has the power to destroy
politicians and that they're willing to
do so and it appears that such fear
isn't totally ill founded according to
the Guardian quote the FBI applied for a
warrant from the FISA Court that's a
foreign intelligence surveillance court
over the summer in order to monitor for
members of the Trump team suspected of a
regular contact with Russian officials
is that legitimate we don't know it's a
revenge on Trump for his constant stream
of criticism of the intelligence
community we don't know the gap that's
growing between Trump and the
intelligence community could his
presidency it could also our
intelligence community
most of all it could trust
Americans have in government and the
people tasked with keeping us safe I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
alrighty so we have lots to get to today
we're going to talk a little bit about
the data esque politics into which we
have descended basically everything in
politics is now a naked guy in a trash
can spewing random words at you and you
have no idea what's going on but you
know that it's hilarious that's that's
essentially what it's come down to if
you've never been to add a piece of data
theater it's most bizarre craft you'll
ever see it's always some random guy who
for no reason in the middle of the show
just gets nude and runs around and then
everybody cheers because they think that
there's a deeper meaning underlying it
that's sort of what our politics has
become except we either root for or
against the naked guy that's pretty much
for our politics if it will get to all
of that in just a second but first we
have to say thank you to our advertisers
over at lift so my wife is a doctor that
means that sometimes has to come from
really late at night and sometimes has
to come home really late at night on
days when she's not allowed to drive so
she takes lift lift is the best car
sharing service the car ride service
that is it is the top of the notch and
the reason that it's top notch the
reason it's the safest is because lyft
drivers are rated after every single
ride so only the best people stick
around you have to worry about getting
into a crappy car with some creepy dude
all of their cars I think have to be
have to be from the last five or six
years that much newer vehicles you're
not going to show and it's not going to
be some dude in a rape van showing up to
pick you up instead it's going to be
somebody who has been verified through a
security check they do a 10 point safety
standard which includes criminal and DMV
background checks you know you're going
to get around quickly and safely you can
also tip in the app which means that
they have happier drivers and happier
customers it's a better all-around
experience they do offer quality over
quantity and it's a great way to avoid
drunk driving to a great way to avoid
having to drive when you're really tired
you never have to bummer I'd you never
have to worry about parking lift is
fantastic service and as I say I trust
my own wife's safety with lifts and she
obviously does too right now lift is
offering our listeners here at the ben
shapiro show a special deal you get
three free rides up to ten dollars each
so a thirty dollar value if you just use
our promo code Shapiro so you get to try
it
see how much you like it and it is great
you're really going to enjoy it download
the lift app and then enter promo code
Shapiro in the payment section and you
get those three free rides that's a
thirty dollar value again promo code
Shapiro lets them know that we sent you
and also allows you get those free rides
from lifts just for being a member of
the ben shapiro show audience so thanks
to lift and make sure that you use their
service download the app use promo code
Shapiro okay so the world is still
falling apart over this whole BuzzFeed
CNN Donald Trump hubba everything is is
is crazy towns and it seems like nobody
has much of an interest in the truth and
as I said yesterday and near the end of
the show usually politics takes place on
a on a chart and the chart goes like
this on the y-axis top to bottom you
have Republicans two Democrats right and
they're people who are anywhere on that
spectrum and then you have an x-axis and
on the x-axis it is truth to falsehood
it's truth to non truth and it seems
lately like the x axis has disappeared
nobody really cares about truth since
today's show is going to be an exercise
in showing just how little people seem
to care about the truth or intellectual
honesty or decency and how it's all
turned into just partisan bickering and
bashing each other which doesn't do the
country any good and isn't likely to
inculcate any sort of trust in Americans
for either the government or the
political process which of course leads
to the rise of demagogues and it's all
very dangerous stuff it's all not good
stuff basically here's my theory about
how 2016 went 2016 the Trump revolution
it really was all of the chickens coming
home to roost people didn't trust the
media Trump rip the media the chicken
came home to roost people didn't trust
Obama the chicken came home to roost in
the form of Donald Trump lots of
chickens coming home to roost the
problem is the left spent so long
maintaining this facade that politics is
decent while ripping away at the heart
of politics ripping away at truth and
decency you lying routinely ripping
their opponents but then putting this
false facade of decency and smoothness
on top that eventually people said screw
it we don't need to sada anymore this
whole thing is a joke all the chickens
have come home to roost at once and what
that means is that there are too many
chickens in the coop now the whole thing
is going to explode all the chickens are
pecking at each other and eating each
other and there's there's not going to
be any chicken left for supper because
they're all going to cannibalize one
another and that's what we're watching
right now
the fuels chaotic it's because it is
chaotic so the media is cannibalizing
itself the power of the politicians are
cannibalizing each other the media are
cannibalizing the politicians the
politicians are cannibalizing the media
now normally I really like conflict in
politics because I think it keeps
everybody honest but it seems to be
happening is because everybody has
fallen into such partisan traps and
refused to acknowledge any sort of truth
at all and even the notion of objective
truth has gone away instead what you
have is chaos not in service of trying
to get at the truth but chaos for its
own sake chaos just for the team sport
of it so we begin today with buzzfeed
falling apart so BuzzFeed obviously made
a mockery of itself by releasing the
35-page memo that includes all of these
ridiculous allegations against president
elect Trump everybody was ripping them
up and down not everybody actually Nate
Silver came out and defended them which
is odd because i don't remember nate
silver defending other people who
released unverified rumors years ago but
nonetheless most of the media are very
unhappy with BuzzFeed for having
released this 35 page memo and for a
good reason if you're the median you're
out to get Trump then BuzzFeed is the
worst thing that ever happened because
BuzzFeed allowed Donald Trump to Guam
you all in with BuzzFeed BuzzFeed
allowed Donald Trump to play the the
media's awful card and that's a very
powerful card to play and he's right but
he was awful so Chuck Todd over at NBC
News he had on Ben Smith of a BuzzFeed
and he asked him some questions as to
why exactly he had released what even
what even Chuck Todd is calling fake
news when Chuck Todd is tearing apart
BuzzFeed and for good reason you know
that things are wild right when Chuck
Todd is suddenly the guardian of truth
and justice in the media you know that
things are going crazy so there are
really two questions for the for the
media today and and they all come back
to the same question does the media Oh
Donald Trump an apology does the media
Oh Donald Trump apology so there are two
issues here and the reason i ask that is
because as we'll see in a minute there's
a lot of people demanding that CNN
apologize to Donald Trump so there are
two things that happened yesterday
better controversial one is the CNN
reporter accosting trump at the at the
press conference and yelling at him and
Trump shutting him down and the other
thing is the actual CNN reports they own
apology for the CNN report so to give
the background again the CNN report
claimed that intelligence community
officials briefed Donald Trump right
they briefed Donald Trump
on these rumors that were going around
regarding his relationship with Russia
they briefed President Obama about that
also that basically CNN reported that
the Trump received a summary of
information contained in a series of
memos that talked about his relationship
with Russia CNN says that Trump was
informed of this Trump denies that
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper who was the one who supposedly
gave the report he released this
statement today he said we also
discussed the private security company
document which was widely circulated in
recent months among the media members of
Congress and congressional staff even
before the intelligence community became
aware of it I emphasize that this
document is not a us Intel community
product I do not believe the leaks came
from within the intelligence community
this is his phone call at Trump today
the intelligence community has not made
any judgment that the information in the
document is reliable we did not rely
upon it in any way for our conclusions
however part of our obligation is to
ensure that policymakers are provided
with the fullest possible picture of any
matters that might affect national
security so clapper seems to be backing
up to CNN report right that's what that
last sentence means if he why else would
he say it's our obligation to ensure
policymakers are provided with the
fullest possible picture that means that
we showed from the document right we
talked to trump about the document Trump
denies that ok so the CNN report at the
very least is disputed it is not an
openly false report as opposed to the
stuff the BuzzFeed release which is
completely unverified and unverifiable
as even BuzzFeed acknowledges so that's
question number two to CNN you have to
apologize to trump for that report so we
start with the first question should
Donald Trump get an apology from the CNN
reporter for this big blow up yesterday
in which Donald Trump shouted fake news
at CNN here's what that blow up looked
like in case you missed it yesterday
it's a disgrace and I think they ought
to apologize to start with Michael Cohn
since you're attacking us can you give
us a question sure no look a personal
life go ahead personal if you are
attacking our news organization not can
you give us a cheer or going to say you
are tracking our news organization
you give us a chance ask a question sir
go ahead sir is a client mr.
president-elect go ahead you say
categorically question they'll feel like
can you give us a CO to be ruining us
can you give us a question be really I'm
you not going to give you can you stay
quatre you are fakes news circa and you
say categorically that nobody know the
president like that I agree ok so this
of course made all the round and this
made people very very upset on the Trump
side of the aisle people were going
crazy saying CNN should apologize here
the Congress person who says that he
wants Jim Acosta fired that's the CNN
reporters Randy Weber from the 14th
district in in Texas he says the CNN
reporter who is disruptive to the press
briefing and disrespectful to trump
should be fired and prohibited from any
press briefings and other people on the
right have said this too so here is
sean's so Sean Spicer says also CNN
should apologize for this reporter
shouting at him here is the White House
incoming press secretary the office of
president elect of President I today's
deserves a level of respect and having a
reporter stand up and basically yell and
scream and act as inappropriately in
rude as he did is a disgrace we're
better than that and he was an
embarrassment to the press corps frankly
beyond the embarrassment that he caused
to the president-elect I think he's an
embarrassment to the press corps because
the rest of the press was behaving
appropriately raising their hand ask to
have questions asked his network had
already had a question answer and I
think he owes an apology not just to the
president-elect but to the entire press
corps for his inappropriate behavior ok
and Sarah Palin put out a statement that
was very similar really really going
after this reporter from CNN and
suggesting that these journalists ought
to be slammed by Trump it says thank God
really literally thank God we're not
facing a third Obama term if you caught
presidents like Trump's first presser
today you saw it thank you for creating
the movement that shook things up to get
America on the right road and then she
says these journalists bad characters
that they are hurt our nation
tremendously they disrespect those who
fought and died to protect America's
freedom of the press they spit on the
graves of our veterans we deem those
reporters and their publications
irrelevant now hope in this arena soars
upon seeing a fearless leader take on
injustice appreciation fills our heart
when our new
it exudes our collective red white and
blue courage in the face of purveyors of
yellow journalism press members have
worked as a herd of lost lazy little
sheep the herd is now decimated and in
interesting language so so she obviously
is very thrilled with all out of people
are thrilled with Trump quashing this
reporter Jim Acosta a lot of people are
very very excited about all of this now
as I say as I say we'll get to sort of
my response to do all of this in a
second it it's very frustrating to lack
intellectual honesty and let's be real
about this there's a lack of
intellectual honesty when the press was
kissing Obama's asked everybody on the
right was very upset about it but when
Matthew Boyle of Breitbart asks a
question like this to Donald Trump
nobody in the right seems particularly
upset here's Matthew Boyle of Breitbart
napping a question to Donald Trump is a
public thing for the space news in all
the stops except in some detail the
course of the election what reforms do
you recommend for this
well I recommend reforms I recommend
people that are that have some moral
compass you know I've been hearing more
and more about I think called fake news
and they talking about people to go and
say all sorts of things but I will tell
you some of the media outlets that I
deal with the fake news more so than
anybody i could name them but i won't
bother but you have few sitting right in
front of us okay to the right so the
right response to to all of this stuff
with CNN and BuzzFeed by basically
becoming what the left was to Obama
right you see you see map oil just
kissing from rear and again you will
talk in a second about the hypocrisy
that exists on the right they don't get
to the apocrypha that exists on the left
which is truly astonishing it really is
but first we have to say thank you to
another one of our advertisers see so so
see so is the best comedy service that
you will ever buy so for 399 a month you
can see so they have an endless supply
of top-shelf comedy you're talking about
all of the episodes of SNL including
back when it was actually really good
The Tonight Show Starring Fallon with my
late night with seth meyers have all
this commercial free they have classics
like 30 rock and parks and rec they even
have saved by the bell episodes no
commercials for any of the stuff they've
all the british comedies the original
office the monty python catalog and they
have a bunch of original series as well
they've a lot of stand-up louis ck who's
a leftist but really really funny they
have hit all of his stand-up comedy at
the hannibal buress they have they have
a bunch of people who are who are really
top notch comedians they have all of
their specials available for 399 a month
if you're in love with comedy you're not
going to do any better than C so my wife
and I are fans of that they have a show
called Harmon quest which is pretty
funny it's written by Dan Harmon the guy
who is behind community and to
live-action improv animated journey into
a fantasy role-playing so mocks the
whole Dungeons and Dragons routine
really really funny series Carmen quest
you should check that out on C so right
now if you go to see so calm and you
type in the promo code Shapiro if you
type in promo code Ben then you will get
a one month free you get one month free
which is a pretty spectacular deal you
get to try it out for months see how
much you like it so you actually i'm
roaming actually you get a free for two
months when you use promo code been at
checkout so go to see so calm right now
two months free with from promo code
been at checkout that see so calm
promo code been if you are a comedy
addict this is the place for you it's
it's ad free again it is it's great
stuff C so calm comedy oh then and then
the code is is that alright so you know
I would like to just remind the right
but before they go completely nuts over
over this Jim Acosta routine where he
said something to a reporter and they
stayed so great the Trump quashed it
flashback this is Neil Monroe Neil
Monroe is a is a reporter for The Daily
Caller or was a reporter for The Daily
Caller and this is him at a press
conference Barack Obama was holding back
in 2013 driven patriotic empty it is
what it is the right thing to do excuse
me sir it's not time for question sir
not while I'm stakin all right so that
was that was Neil Monroe jumping in well
Obama was talking and asking him a
question as to why he was treating
illegal immigrants better than American
citizens Tucker Carlson who was you know
kind of egging Sean Spicer along calling
for an apology from Jim Acosta I'm old
enough to remember when Tucker Carlson
defended his reporter Neil Monroe in
fact he went ahead and he said that Neil
Monroe was doing a service at the time
he said quote this is what reporters are
supposed to do they're supposed to get
their questions answered it's hard to
know what's wrong with asking the
president a question so now the shoes on
the other foot and of course nobody
cares about the truth so we all have to
pretend that something great and
glorious happened here as opposed to the
CNN reporter asked a question Trump
ignored and Trump has every right to do
that that reporter has every right to
badger Trump I like the adversarial
relationship I think it's actually
something that's kind of good okay so
that's how the right responded the West
responded with similarly absurd
ridiculous hypocrisy so here's how the
left responded to all of so Trevor Noah
the least funny person in America he and
Amy Schumer have been and Lena don't
have been a three-way running gun battle
for that title the least funny person in
the United States Trevor Noah from
Comedy Central he says that this was a
frightening moment this moment at the
press conference word from steamrolled
Jim Acosta that was a frightening moment
you know what honestly that was one of
the most frightening moments of today's
press her for me because in America the
press is supposed to be a check on the
president not the other way around and
you realize this
essentially the first step in the
authoritarian tangle that's what you do
you shut down one news organization by
alleging that it's all fake that's your
move all right and then if you get away
with it you can shut down another news
Odin network no you can shut down 11 use
way to shut down 11 News Network shut
them down shopped enough until all
that's left is breaking news has
president Trump been working out okay so
I love the fact that the left is now
suddenly on board with the idea that
it's terrible to shut down news networks
when Barack Obama was ripping Fox News
regularly wouldn't do an interview with
them virtually the entire news cycle
when he was campaigning in 2008 he threw
reporters he didn't like off his
campaign plane now the left magically
has discovered that it's bad when some
of their own reporters come in Trump's
crosshairs again i want to show you this
is how the left respondent aniol monroe
remember i just showed you the neil
monroe video and the right said good for
nill monroe here's how the left
respondents neil monroe this is from
MSNBC at the time has actually been some
genuine bipartisan agreement on mr.
Munro's actions there I would hope so I
mean no one questions the right of a of
any American but particularly our
journalists asking the President of the
United States a question where Neal
Monroe crossed the line by a mile is by
questioning the president before he even
finished before he even finished
speaking one and also yelling out a
question where he knew questions
wouldn't be wouldn't be okay Jonathan
shut up I'm asking you a question mr.
crystal there are some true believers
who are actually defending mr. Munro's
you know and on cox they were suggesting
a parallel with a moment from the
iran-contra scandal where the press and
reagan had a similar kind of conflict
but if i understand it he'd actually
finished right similar except for one
important thing which is that he had
actually finished his statement before
the question was loved but I you know
credit where credit is due it's good to
see some criticism from Fox News to Neil
Monroe okay so they're all happy that
there was criticism of Neil Monroe now
Jim Acosta is a great hero of the same
people on the left I love how Jonathan
Capehart basically implies Danielle
Monroe's a racist for asking a question
in the middle of Obama's statement which
is pretty incredible we have to take a
break on facebook
if you want to see the rest then you'll
have to go over to daily wire.com and
check it out their daily we're not
coming come and subscriber for eight
dollars a month you can see the rest of
this program you can also be part of the
mailbag we only answer questions from
people our subscribers and we will
answer live questions from subscribers a
little bit later on the show so you can
check that out as well and so that will
be very exciting day Lee Weyer calm if
you become an annual subscriber you
still get a signed copy of my book true
allegiance and I think we have another
goodie coming up in the next couple of
weeks for annual subscribers as well so
go over and subscribe right now at daily
wire calm we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
you